it's been an awful year for Apple at
least by the company's high standards
and I have an uninspiring message for
the company's fans and investors
wondering when Apple's tide will turn
wait until next year apples revenue has
declined for the last two quarters and
probably will continue to fall for the
next six months the last time Apple
sales dropped for twelve months straight
was 2001 Mark Zuckerberg was still in
high school
Apple stock has also dropped 26% from an
all-time high in February 2015 the
company's product wizards are keeping
busy but the next year won't be a
blockbuster the newly updated iPhones
Apple will show off and an event on
Wednesday no matter what they're called
will be more like tweaked versions of
the iPhone 6s breaking with Apple's
pattern of having significant updates in
even-numbered years also coming our
fresh models of some Mac computers and a
second-generation Apple watch
none of these products will be surprises
but they should help apples sales grow
again at least modestly after this
holiday season the big hopes for major
sales rebound are riding on 2017
expectations are building that Apple
will pull out a dramatically different
iPhone a year from now with a new type
of super thin screen that could spark a
big wave of new iPhone sales it's been
five years since Tim Cook took over as
Apple CEO and the company has become
even more financially successful but it
doesn't have a break out new Wow product
category under his watch wait until next
year isn't a great rallying cry but it's
the best Apple can do